is here and on the mic
so good to be home boys get me on the
line jack you know what i mean
hey it's been a solid two years of
drinking these at home
so happy to be back uh it was uh
february of 2020 then we went to the
bubble then it was tampa and here we are
feels good doesn't it though it feels
good to see you guys back
i swear you guys are reverse aging it's
like a benjamin button thing going on
you guys look great suits are looking
immaculate
it is pre-season you know we're trying
to get it all straight you know what i
mean i know honestly but everything's
feeling great looking great so great to
be around people again see all these
faces you know
it really is i'm feeling i'm feeling in
high spirits boys
[Laughter]
happy to have you in high spirits i got
my brother showtime with me today we see
that showtime definitely a an amazing
baller from the city spreading a lot of
positivity to the kids so i brought him
to the game today with me you know
showing a lot of love look at this young
team
yet barnes and bantam out at the house
of course of course that's my guys d-boy
real trench baby and so and so how did
it look out there did they run out there
no i don't know you didn't want to no
it's really early in the morning from
what i remember
it was delirious
i was finishing the album i was
absolutely delirious i don't remember
anything
i think somebody i woke up in the pool
that day from what i remember
jack's done that before
hey you know what it doesn't make me a
bad guy
talk to me how you guys been how's
everything good yeah just you know what
you walk back in the energy the people
as you said it's just good to be back
courtside it certainly is seeing fans in
the stands the last time i saw you you
gave me a fred rico hat remember that
the birth of a legend though no
down stuck with us too god bless his
heart i still have the hat yeah he loved
it we got to bring it back up
he rode that frederico for a while still
is look at him
still riding that way for sure
how about the timing of that
i appreciate you guys having me back on
the air though
any time you know that yeah that's why
happy birthday to your son with fourth
birthday today son turned four today
right had the party right yesterday i'm
certain i'm turning 24 on the 24th it's
my champion my champagne birthday
no i'm getting old this year i'm getting
older this year but my true not true i
mean you know it is what it is it
happens we've been holding it down for
the city for a long time by the way i
know the city's watching today i just
want to send my love to everybody you
know
it was a it was a tough fight it was a
tough fight for for for the last couple
years and
i just want to send my regards to my
love to everybody you know i hope
everyone's doing well
as as uh
as well
oh yeah sorry we got to talk about the
game but as well as possible with with
the given circumstances but just want to
send my love to the city thank you for
the support on the album you know i love
you guys so much man i can't wait to see
you again do a concert in this building
have the boys there you know yeah we'll
be there
you can you can make it a casual night
that night you know we don't have to
bring a tie and no you can go like nick
nurse like dress shoes with the with the
raptors warm-up
or we'll just borrow your jacket yeah
yeah exactly that would look great
though
the raptor has one i think i know i
debated about this jacket for way too
long now i kind of regret it i just went
with something way more subtle you know
you can get away with good yeah it was a
definitely this isn't a pre-season look
that's a game seven yes i saw myself on
camera i realized this is definitely a
round round
two second round look but it is what it
is how about wainwright making
back-to-back threes maddie because he
knows we're on the air that's right he
knows you're calling his game excellent
yeah
take it away wayne wright was right
there and then here's david johnson but
also
drake as well it's you know thanksgiving
oh wainwright's got wayne right hot oh
i i i jinxed that front rim
and tied up but so
all the words that you were just saying
so thankful to on this thanksgiving
right yes exactly exactly
well here he is wainwright knocking down
a jimmy drake there's one
there's another one right here flynn
edition
malachi
we're in 22. we're in the nike gt's
yeah going
going new school on them for sure
wearing the nike gt cuts i believe
they're called they're all cuts yeah
they're gt cuts
looking good yeah looking good you got
the golf thing going too oh yeah nike
yeah i don't really know
you know like
who's really great at golf at the end
nico's pretty good i heard you my
uncle's my uncle's incredible that's
that yeah well drake i'm really good at
the 19th hole
i kick tail take no prisoners i love
that
yeah here nico's uh his game has
improved he's still working on it yeah
he's deeply invested in in the golf
thing a lot of my friends are t-rex is
uh is invested too it's great you know
it's a it's a
you have like a goblin you have a golf
simulator not yet not yet that's
something it's putting green at the
house
i'll get that going for you for sure
i'll come over you don't need the
putting green for him
[Laughter]
just had the 19th hole ready
he's all good okay
okay josh they look good
[Applause]
glenn yeah
drake called it cash money
let's go
it's a 30 bag oh it's a 20 bag
well we've had two of those tonight
beat the clock boys are fired up man
what can i say